[موسيقى]
لقد فعلتها قطر بالاصاله عن نفسها
وبالاصاله نفسها للمسلمين والعرب فنابت
عنهم بتنظيم اول وارقى واضخم مونديال في
العالم
من وسائل تجعل النسخه الثانيه والعشرين
لكاس العالم للعام 2020
والاهم من ذلك كله ان قطر جمعت بين كره
القدم ولغه العقل في تظاهره ثقافيه رياضيه
لان اجتماع الشعوب على الود والفرح يسمو
بالاحترام المتبادل للتقاليد والثقافات
والوسطيه التي تكرم الضيوف وتحترم طرائق
عيش المضيفين
قطر ستبقى حره تسمو بروح الاوفياء يقول
نشيدها الوطني ويضيف سيروا على نهج الاولى
سيرو وعلى ضياء الانبياء وعلى ضياء
الانبياء في قطر كاس العالم اكبر من كاس
خمره والملاعب الخضراء ستبقى خضراء سندسيه
لن تتغير الوانها او تتقوس لان الهويه فوق
الهوايه الى العناويه
مونديال قطر
2022 الهويه فوق الهوايه
حمله اسرائيليه شرسه ضد قطر
بمشاركه علاء حسني مبارك وفولول
انفانتينو لن يموت مشجعون الملاعب اذا
توقفوا عن شرب البيره
صحفي فرنسي يشكو من كثره مساجد المسلمين
في الدوحه
ذاكر المئات يسيرون اسلامهم على هامش
كاس العالم
رئيس الجزائر دفاعا عن الانجاز العربي كل
دي نعمه محسود
اعلام السعوديه والكويت يدعم المونديال
وعصومي البحرين ينفذ اجندا خارجيا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا اي كلام اعظم من كلام الله لتفتتح
به قطر المونديال الاسطوره الايه الكريمه
تحض على الاجتماع في مواجهه الفرقه وعلى
التعارف في مقابل التنافر فهل ثمه من
يعارض مقاصدها
قراها صاحب الهمه الشاب القطري الملهم
غانم المفتاح السفير الرسمي لبطوله كاس
العالم
غانم المفتاح
لطالما كان مفتاح تفاؤل للشباب العربي
بحلول دائما تغلب العثرات وكان الى جانبه
ايقونه الفن السابع الامريكي مورجان
فريمان الذي قدم الى الدوحه باعوامه 85
ليقول ان البشر اسره واحده وان اختلفت
الوانه
وعقائدهم ابوهم ادم عليه السلام وامهم
و فلماذا نستنفر الترسانات والاساطير
ونكرر مشهدا قابيل وهابيل لنتوزع بين قاتل
وقتيل يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من ذكر
وانثى
وجعلناكم شعوبا
وقبائل لتعارفوا ان اكرمكم عند الله
اتراكم في مبادئنا الاسلاميه واعرافنا
العربيه يكبر المرء باهله ولا يكبر على
اهله فبروا الوالدين فضيله يتوسلها الكبير
والصغير الامير والفقير من قطر من بلاد
العرب ترحيب اميري بتوقيعي تميم بن حمد ال
ثاني بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
من قطر
من بلاد العرب
ارحب بالجميع في بطوله كاس العالم
2022 سوف يجتمع الناس
على اختلاف اجناسهم
وجنسياتهم
هنا في قطر
وحول الشاشات في جميع القارات للمشاركه في
لحظات الاثاره ذاتها
ما اجمل ان يضع الناس ما يفرقهم جانبا لكي
يحتفوا بتنوعهم وما يجمعهم في الوقت ذاته
ولتكن اياما ملهمه بالخير والامل اهلا
وسهلا بالعالم في دوحه الجميع
[تصفيق]
لاول مره في التاريخ بايات قرانيه كريمه
فلقد سجلت قطر بذلك هدفها الاول للتعريف
بجوهر الاسلامي وحكمته وتسامحه في المقابل
مذياع من مصر يبدو انه قد حالنا الى زمن
حكم عائله مبارك فتناغم مع علاء الدين
وفانوس فلوسه السحري في انتقاد قطر وكانه
ينتقد بين السطور تلبيه الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي دعوه امير قطر الى افتتاح
كاس العالم هذا المذياع الذي سبق ان دعا
الى تعطيل العمل باحكام القران الكريم
ينكر على قطر افتتاحها المونديال بايه
قرانيه بل يعتبروا التعريف بالاسلام جريمه
علما ان هذا المجرم وف توصيفي حقوقيين سبق
ان دعى المصريين على الهواء الى ذبح
اعلاميين معارضين على قارعه الطريق في
مختلف دول العالم قطر او الناس اللي
بينظموا المونديال في قطر يعني بيرتكبوا
جريمه لما يحط الاحاديث ويترجمها في
الشارع في الشوارع هناك وكانه هو بيدعو
الشعوب اللي جايه دي لجماهير الى الاسلام
يلاقي هذا المذياع مغردون اسرائيليون مثل
مائير المصري الذي يصف نسخه القطريه
الاسطوره بافشل مونديال في التاريخ فيما
يعتبروا زميله اديكان ان قطر تحاول اسلمت
المونديال وذلك في سياق حمله اسرائيليه
شرسه ضد قطر بدات قبيله انطلاقه المونديال
ولم تهدا بعد وماذا تنتظرون من الاعلام
العبري بعد تحول لصاحات المشجعين في
الدوحه الى منابره للتعبير عن التشبه
بحقنا في فلسطين وبحق فلسطين علينا
[موسيقى]
مواطن قطري دشن سلسله الرفض الشعبي لاجراء
مقابلات مع قنوات اسرائيليه دخلت الدوحه
ضمن شروط الفيفا على البلد المضيء
برودكا
ومحافظ على موقف اتجاه القضيه الفلسطينيه
روموت همم
[موسيقى]
فلسطين فلسطين
وتهتف لحريتها من قلب الدوحه
ما شاء الله فلسطين
فلسطين
[موسيقى]
عن حقوق الانسان
وهم يحتلون شعب اخر
يتحدثون عن يتحدثون
يا رحمن
قطريا بل هي ثقافه امه تحفظها اين مكانك
في الدوحه او في اقاصي الارض دون تطرف او
تقرير ليست الاسماء والعناوين مهمه في
مسيره الدفاع عن التراث قطر رفعت الراس
واسم شعبي عربي على تويتر دسنه مغردون بعد
الاعلان عن قرار قطر حضر بيع الخمور في
الملاعب الثمانيه لمباريات المونديال وهذا
بعد مناقشات بين سرطان بلد المضيف والفيفا
وهي المره الاولى التي تقام فيها البطوله
في دوله اسلاميه محافظه تفرض تفرض قيود
صارمه على المشروبات الكحوليه وتحضر
تناولها في الاماكن العامه
اذا امتنعوا عن تناول الكحولي لثلاثه
ساعات يؤكد رئيس هذه الدوليه لكره القدم
جياني انفانتينو لكن وضع مدرب السويد حرج
للغايه فهو سيصاب بالجنون لو منع عن
احتساء البيره كمسجع هناك اكثر من 10
مناطق للمشجعين حيث يمكن لاكثر من 100,000
شخص شرب الكحول في نفس الوقت ومئه الف شخص
في اي لحظه معينه اعتقد شخصيا اذا لم
تتمكن من شرب الجرعه لمده ثلاث ساعات في
اليوم فستعيش
حفاظا على السلامه العامه
فقط هويتها المسلمه يقول رئيس الفيفا
ان نفس القواعد تنطبق في فرنسا واسبانيا
والبرتغال واسكتلندا حيث يمنع تناول
البيره في الملاعب وهنا اا الموضوع احداث
ضجه كبيره ولا افهم لذلك ربما لانها دوله
مسلمه
من الاوروبيين الاعتذار للشعوب على مدار
ثلاثه الاف عام مقبله قبل اعطاء الدروس في
الحريات وحقوق العمال للقطريين
ويوافقه بيار مرجان الصحفي البارز في قناه
فوكس نيوز مذكرا الغرب بتدبيره العراق
المثليين في مونديال قطر بان ربع الدولي
المشاركه في نهائيات العالم حضرت المثليه
فهل ستطردونها من المباريات انفجار
كابنونين
[موسيقى]
وقال علينا
سمعناها في الدوحه بصوت المغني الايرلندي
لا يحب الهدوء فمن هو ذاك الفرنسيه هذا لو
ان مراسلا مسلم ابتعث لتغطيه في فرنسا
وساله المذيعه هل تواجه مشاكل في باريس
فقال نعم توجد هنا كنائس كثيره
والطبخ في العالم بانه داعشي قاعديا
اسلاماوي متطرف متشدد ولا وجب على وسيمته
الاعلاميه طرده فورا في محاكمه عدديه
فوريه وعلى دولته ملاحقته بتهمه التخطيط
لحروب طائفيه
لقد فعلها صحفي فرنسي ببساطه لكن من موقع
مختلف فتذمر على الهواء من وجود المساجد
في الدوحه كما يتذمر من كثره الماء في
البحر او من كثره امثال جاكو هذا في فرنسا
قال في معرض الشكوى يوجد هنا الكثير من
المساجد وانتهت مشاركته المباشره بضحك
جماعي من المذيع والضيوف في استديوهات
باريس
ابوك المشكله
[ضحك]
العربي مشجعون منتخب كرواتيا باللباس
الخليجي في اجواء احتفاليه داخل سوق واقف
في قلب العاصمه القطريه
هذا ما تصحف هنديه متطرفه الداعيه
الاسلاميه العالمي ذاكر بعد حضوره
الى الدوحه لمواكبه الفعاليات الثقافيه
الموازيه لكاس العالم لكن الشيخ ذاكر الذي
كما قال احد اصدقائه منعوه من السفر الى
الناس في العالم للدعوه الى الله فجاءه
الناس الى قطر ليدعوهم الى الله هو اعلن
بحسب مجله مين عن اعتناق نحو 900 شخص
الاسلام على هامش المونديال في اطار برامج
التعريفي بالاسلام التي اطلقتها وزاره
الشؤون الاسلاميه القطريه
رسول الله
لاول مره في تاريخ كاس العالم ملاعب صممت
لتحترم صلاه المسلمين في اوقاتها اما
موسيقى حفلات المشجعين فتاخذ استراحه
لدقيقتين احتراما للاذان الذي وصفه صحفي
برازيلي بانه من اجمل الاشياء التي سمعها
في حياته
قام امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
الثاني حفل استقبالا لقاده الدول ورؤساء
الوفود المشاركين في افتتاح بطوله كاس
العالم شهد لقاءات ثنائيه بين عدد من
القاده وترافق هذا الحفل مع التعبير عن
الاعتزاز بتنظيم قطر لحادث بطوله كاس
العالم وتقدير الجهود التي مكنت من توفيره
افضل الظروف والتوقف عند الرسائل اللافته
التي شهدها الافتتاح عن اهميه دور كره
القدم في جمع الانسانيه دون تفرقت كل ذي
نعمه محسود يرددها الرئيس الجزائري عبد
المجيد تبون ردا على الحملات المعاديه
لمونديال العرب في قطر
عالمي ان اليوم نفتخر
الدول العربيه
كله دي نعمه محسود قطر في عيون الكويت
والعرب كلهم في عيونها وزاره الاعلام
الكويتيه تدعم قطر على طريقتها
وتمم عليها النعمه وترزقها خير النجاح يا
الله
اخلاق عاليه روحي رياضيه وتنافس شريف
وهالسنه الكره احلى لانها في بيتنا ومكان
لانها في قطر وكل العيون على قطر
قطر في عيون الكويت ومن قناه الاخباريه
السعوديه تقرير ينتقد النفاق الغربي في
التعامل مع قطر ومع الامه جمعاء قطر هذه
المره في مواجهه الهجمه الغربيه المزدوجه
والحجمه منحاز اعتدتها السعوديه من قبل
والمنطقه بدولها والشعوبها وان تلبست لبوس
مختلفا تشكله سبب المناسبه غير انها تنطلق
وفق المعياريه الغربيه الا اخلاقيه التي
مازالت عجزه عن تعريف من هو الانسان كل
العرب والمسلمين يدعمون قطر في تثبيته
هويتها التي هي هويتهم في الحدث العالمي
الاكبر فقط اصحاب النكد والحسد كانوا كما
تعودوا في عكس اتجاه الامه فقر لم تبهر
العالم بافتتاح الاقل من عدي بحسب توصيفه
احدهم يقول عبد الله بن المقفع صحبه
الاخيار تورث الخير وصحبه الاشرار تورث
الندامه بين مغردين نكد والحسد والنجم
العربي محمد ابو تريكه من تختارون ان يكون
في صفكم دونوا ان رغبتم والعالم مدين
وقطر ان شاء الله سوف تبهر العالم وسوف
نفتخر بها كعرب وكمسلمين ان دوله عربيه
اسلاميه تعتز بالهويه بتاعتها وبتقاليدها
انا بحب قطر وبدا القطر قبيلا انطلاق
المونديال كان الرئيس الدولي للبرلمان
العربي البحريني عادل العسومي يختطف
برلمان العرب واهدافه للعمل القومي
المشترك فيرفض اذن تحملات التحريض ضد قطر
ضد العرب والمسلمين فاستنكر مكتب مجلس
الشورى القطري موقف العسومي الخادمه
خارجيه فهل ثمه ما ينقذ البرلمان العربيه
العريق من لعب الاستاذ عصومي الذي لم يعد
الحياه البرلمانيه الا في مجلس البحرين
وديمقراطيه الزحليقه والنطيطه عاتب مجلس
الشورى القطري ياتي بعد ان رفض عادل
العسومي رئيس البرلمان العربي اصدار بيان
يدين الحملات التي تتعرض لها الدوحه على
خلفيه استضافتها كاس العالم بينما كان
الاجدي به دعم دوله شقيقه الحمد لله الذي
ابدلنا بدل الدرهم دينارا قيلت يوما
للحجاج واعاد تجسدها اطفال غزه الذين
منحوا المونديال دفئه دعمهم بوقفه تعبيريه
هي اغلى من كل البيانات الرسميه المدرب
التونسي واللاعب الدولي السابق قيس
اليعقوبي يرفع التحيه لقطر ليس مجامله لها
بل جميله حرصها على سياده احكامها وعلى
عدم تفريطها بدينها يقول شكرا افتكر هذا
انتصار البلد عربي ومسلم وانتصار خاصه
لهذا الدين الحنيف اللي يحبوشوه بارك الله
فيكم طبعا برنامج فوق السلطه لن يتناول
الحدث من البعد الرياضي فللامر نشرات
وبرامج متخصصه لكن هل نستطيع ان نغادر
الحلقه قبل ان نقول مليون مليون مبروك
للسعوديه فوزها على الارجنتين والامل
بمزيد من الفوز للسعوديه ولكافه الفرق
العربيه الاخرى في المونديال
مشجعون سعوديون ارسلوا لنا فيديو يعكس
درجه الامن والامان في الدوحه نعرضه كما
هو
السعودي جاب هذا المكان انا جيت هنا
اتغديت ونسيت الشنطه ورحت بالباص والمتر
وصلت
مع الحماس
والجرينتا على قولهم
افتكرت انه الشنطه نسيتنا المكان
اللهم لك الحمد
اخيرا لابد من التنويه بان اخبار كثيره
تجاوزناها هذا الاسبوع وخصصنا الحلقه
لمونديال قطر بابعاده الثقافيه والاعلاميه
علما ان بعض هذه الاخبار كان مثيرا للجدل
مثل الفيديو انتشر لصفعه على خدي الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون قيل انها جديده
وقد سددتها سيده بتمريره ناجحه من بين
الرجال الامن لكن ماكرون والحضور كانوا
يضعون الكمامات المنزوعه الان وقد اوضحت
فرانسبريس ان السبعه ليست جديده وتعود
لاحدى المناسبات السابقه
بكل الاحوال كانت صفعه جديده او قديمه
فليست الاولى وربما لن تكون الاخيره فهل
نترك الاحتفاء بمونديال العرب الاول في
التاريخ ونذهب الى صفحه او رشقه بيض بتصير
كل كم يوم مع مكروه
[موسيقى]
ختاما هذا المونديالو اللؤلؤي الذي كلف
عشرات المليارات هو مونديال للفقراء ايضا
الذين بنوا عن قرب وبنوا شيئا من فرحهم
عليه عن بعد في مخيمات النزوح السوريه
وغيرها نصبت شاشات عملاقه عابره للتشفير
تحت شعار المونديال للجميع لتكون ملحقا
رمزيا لمشاديه الدوحه وملعبا تاسعا يتسع
لكل تواق
لسلوى لبضع ساعات يتناسى خلالها همومه بعد
ان نسيه القريب والبعيد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]